just talk us through the findings of
this report
well you've read the report the report
is I think uh pretty uh brutal what we
found is that Richard Sharp the BBC
chair has broken the rules the rules
quite clearly say that if you apply for
a public service job like this you've
got to be completely open about any
conflict of interest now Mr Sharp
facilitated an enormous 800 000 pound
loan to Boris Johnson the then prime
minister and it was Boris Johnson who
appointed Richard Sharp As BBC chair so
clearly that's a conflict of interest he
didn't tell his interview panel and he
didn't tell us as MPS who are then asked
to consider his appointment and um when
he appeared before us last week he
didn't seem to think that he'd done
anything wrong which I found perplexing
because clearly he broke the rules we
knew he was a big Tory party donor we
knew he'd given 400
000 pounds to the Tories that's not
against the rules which is I was going
to say that's not against the rules and
we knew about that I think it's wrong I
don't think you should be giving huge
amounts of money and then getting a plum
job from the people you've given money
to think that's wrong but as you say
it's not against the rules but we didn't
know anything about this huge loan to
Boris Johnson
I want to just come in now with Mr
Sharp's uh statement because I think
it's important of course to put his
point of view across as well he said
that he did breathe the cabinet
secretary about the appointment and that
he was never involved in the arrangement
of a loan between Mr Blythe and Mr
Johnson so let's just have a look at a
statement now he says Mr Sharp
appreciates that there was information
that the committee felt that it should
have been made aware of in his
pre-appointment hearing your point he
regrets this and apologizes and then he
goes on to say it was in seeking at the
time to ensure that the rules were
followed and in the belief that this had
been achieved that Mr Sharp acted in
good faith in the way he did that's the
defense well that's a load of old
flannel isn't it I mean that doesn't
really mean anything at all he
appreciates the committee's upset uh why
is he not sorry he had a long session
with us where he could have said he
could have put his hands up he could
have showed a bit of humility I mean he
does apologize to be fair he says he
regrets this and apologize he could have
apologized when he was in front of the
committee he's apologizing no because he
sees how brutal the report is and he's
fighting for his job but I think one of
the problems as well was just his
General approach to the committee when
he appeared before MPS cross-party
committee he was just so haughty and
entitled and if I'd been him and I'd
realize that I'd done something as badly
wrong as he had done I think I'd have
apologized on the spot and said I'd made
a mistake and he didn't do that he sat
before us for the whole hearing and
failed to apologize at any point uh now
you I just want to say you're obviously
your committee has a really important
role in accepting the appointment of the
chair and at the time you said you
didn't know all the facts I just want to
have a look at what your committee
acting chair Damien green had to say
conservative Damien green he said such a
significant air of judgment meant that
we were not in the full possession of
the facts when we were required to rule
on his suitability for the role of BBC
chair if you knew then what you know now
do you think the appointment would have
gone through I can't speak for other
members of the committee because we
didn't know what we know then what we we
know know but it's it's absolutely clear
that when he filled out the application
form in fact I read out the application
form rules to him that he had to sign to
say that there was nothing in his past
that could potentially cause
embarrassment either to him or to the
BBC clearly the BBC is enormously
embarrassed by this and BBC staff I know
because they're writing to to meet huge
numbers BBC staff are very upset about
this they're upset about the way that
he's behaved as chair
because he he imposed himself on a board
to choose the the head of BBC News and
current affairs he's not a journalist he
should be doing that so they're worried
about political interference and I think
for BBC staff now they've lost
confidence in him so it's difficult to
see how he can carry on how many have
written to you then roughly
scores scores of BBC staff written to
you and would you have come to a
different conclusion I know you can't
talk about members of the committee but
would you have come to additional
conclusion yourself well
my my view always is that people who've
given huge donations to political
parties should not be appointed to
Public Service roles that is my ongoing
View and I think Pierre starmer now if
he wants to clean up politics when he
becomes prime minister if he becomes
prime minister I think he should now say
that anybody who's given a large
donation to labor or any other political
party should not get a public service
Rule and that he will not give big
public service jobs to donors to the
labor party because this is key isn't it
because a lot of people will be looking
at this and say look you guys only kick
up a fast when it's a conservative
supporter who gets a job well I think I
think they say that to the labor party
they don't say that to my party if you
look at you know James Pannell Gavin
Davis Greg Dyke they all had
affiliations to labor they all went into
top jobs in the BBC some people might
think well maybe this is a bit of a
rebalancing well I don't think that I
think it's wrong for any party to
receive large amounts of money and for
the party that receives the money then
to appoint the person concerned to top
job as I said to Mr Sharp it's all about
Banana Republic Banana Republic you
think that's a really is a strong
statement there and of course it matters
because the BBC's reputation hinges on
impartiality millions of people trust it
uses new services do you believe that
BBC is impartial
I think the BBC aims to be impartial
there's always going to be questions
over individual presenters or reporters
but the BBC Prides itself on its
impartiality I'm a former BBC presenter
and youth presenter as you know I was a
newsnite and other programs presented
BBC breakfast and certainly when I was a
presenter nobody ever tried to tell me
what to do what to say or what to ask
that's my personal experience I guess Mr
sharp would say that look with these
bigger public appointments you attract
people who believe in public service and
that's why you get people who have made
donations or are affiliated to parties
right so Mr Sharp has shown no interest
in broadcasting throughout his career
barring one application that he told us
about he previously applied for a job on
the board of the BBC he wasn't even
interviewed to paraphrase Mrs Martin
what was it about this application
following the 800 000 pound facility
that first attracted Boris Johnson to
him as BBC chair is this position
untenable
I don't see how you can carry on how can
you argue with the BBC's case how can he
talk about impartiality give them that
he withhold withheld this important
information from us and given the low
levels of trust that he now enjoys
amongst BBC staff
thank you very much indeed for your time
on the program